en este vídeo voy a hacer más ejercicios
de simplificación de expresiones
radicales van a ser expresiones que van
a involucrar sumas y restas de
diferentes radicales pienso que esta es
una buena herramienta para ti
así es que hagamos algunos de estos
supongamos que tenemos tres por la raíz
cuadrada de 8 y ya hemos aprendido que
esta es la raíz cuadrada principal menos
6 por la raíz cuadrada principal de 32
veamos que podemos hacer para
simplificar esto 8 lo podemos escribir
como 2 por 4 y 4 bueno ya es un cuadro
perfecto podrías escribirlo como 2 por 2
pero no necesitamos hacer eso así es que
este primer término lo podemos escribir
como 3 por raíz cuadrada de 4 y por raíz
cuadrada de 2 esto es lo mismo que la
raíz cuadrada de 4 por 2 que es lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada de 8 este término
es el mismo que este otro término ahora
32 lo podemos factorizar como
2 x 16 2 x 16 y 16 es un cuadro perfecto
podemos continuar factor izando esto
como 4 x 4 y más aún cada uno de los
cuatros como 2 por 2 pero al ser dice es
un cuadro perfecto ya podemos dejar
hasta aquí la factorización así es que
esta segunda expresión la podemos
escribir como 6 por la raíz cuadrada de
16 y por la raíz cuadrada de 2 esta
expresión de aquí la podemos escribir
como la raíz cuadrada de 16 por 2
puedes escribir esto como la raíz
cuadrada de 16 por 2 o como la raíz
cuadrada 16 por la raíz cuadrada de 2
eso lo vimos cuando estudiamos las
propiedades de los exponentes que
tenemos entonces aquí tenemos 3 por la
raíz cual principal de 4 que es 2 así es
que aquí tenemos 3 por 2 raíz cuadrada
de 2 que es 6 por la raíz cuadrada de 2
eso menos 6
aquí tenemos raíz cuadrada 16 que es 4x
sería 6 por 4 raíz de 2 que es 24 por la
raíz cuadrada de 2 y no hemos terminado
aquí sí tenemos seis de algo y le
estamos restando 24 desea algo que nos
da 6 raíz cuadrada de 2 - 24 raíz
cuadrada de 2 eso nos va a dar igual a 6
menos 24 es igual a menos 18 raíz
cuadrada de 2 y espero que éste no te
confundas si tienes 6 x menos 24 x va a
ser igual a menos 18 x nada más que
tienes en vez de x la escuadra de 2 así
es que si tenemos 6 de algo menos 24 de
algo obtenemos menos 18 de ese álbum
hagamos otro supongamos que tenemos la
raíz cuadrada de 180 más 6 por la raíz
cuadrada de 405 estos son ejercicios de
simplificación de expresiones radicales
que ya hemos hecho varios con
anterioridad pero nunca está de más
hacer ejercicios de este tipo hagamos la
factorización de ciento ochenta 180 es
igual a 2 por 90 y esto es igual a 2
45 y esto es igual a 5 por 9 y 9 lo
podríamos factorizar como 3 por 3 pero
al ser 9 un cuadrado perfecto podemos
detener aquí la factorización así es que
este primer término lo puedo escribir
como la raíz cuadrada de 2 por 2 que
multiplica a la raíz cuadrada de 5 y que
multiplica la raíz cuadrada de 9 voy a
poner la raíz cuadra de 9 al principio
tenemos así la raíz cuadrada de 2 por 2
por la raíz cuadrada de 5 y eso por la
raíz cuadrada de 9 ya eso le vamos a
sumar vamos a factorizar la raíz cuadra
de 405 esto es igual a 5 por 81 déjame
cerciorarme si esto está correcto 405
entre 54 entre 5 no cabe 40 entre 5 es
igual a 88 por 540 restamos 40 menos 40
es cero bajamos este 555 es 1 si esto es
5 por 81 81 lo podemos factorizar como 9
por 9 y podemos continuar factor izando
como 3 por 3 cada uno de estos 9
ya tenemos cuadros perfectos aquí así es
que aquí vamos a dejar la factorización
de tal manera que el segundo término
resulta entonces 6 por la raíz cuadrada
de 9 por 9 es 9 por merck último es aquí
y por la raíz cuadrada de 5 que tenemos
entonces aquí tenemos raíz cuadrada de 9
que es 3 luego raíz cuadrada de 2 por 2
que es la raíz cuadrada de 4 que es
igual a 2 y esto que multiplica a la
raíz cuadrada de 5 más aquí tenemos la
raíz cuadrada de 9 por 9 que es la raíz
cuadrada 81 que es 9 por supuesto así 6
por 9 es igual a 54 por lo cual este
segundo término es 54 raíz cuadrada de 5
que tenemos finalmente finalmente
tenemos 6 de algo al cual vamos a sumar
54 desde algo y eso nos va a dar igual a
60 bs
así de simple hagamos un último
ejercicio de este tipo vamos a ser un
ejemplo más abstracto vamos a incluir
variables aquí pero te voy a mostrar que
en realidad esto no cambia las cosas
supongamos que tenemos la raíz cuadrada
la raíz principal de 48 a más la raíz
cuadrada
de 27 a hagamos la factorización de 48
48 lo podemos escribir como 2
24 24 como 2 por 12 perdón 2 por 12 y 2
se lo puedo escribir como 3 por 4
aquí ya podemos concluir dado que 4 es
un cuadrado perfecto así es que este
primer término lo podemos escribir como
la raíz de dos por dos
la raíz de 4 y por la raíz de 3 claro
desde un principio podemos haber
considerado que 48 lo podemos escribir
como 16 por 3 pero hicimos por ponerlo
así el procedimiento de fuerza bruta
para extraer estos factores nos falta
incluir a en el término el cual ponemos
como raíz de 3 por lo ponemos dentro un
mismo radical porque ya pues la raíz
cuadra de 3 a ya no se puede reducir más
y el segundo término lo vamos a escribir
como vamos a factorizar 27-27 ese factor
y za como 3 por 9 podemos aquí concluir
la factorización dado que 9 es un
cuadrado perfecto así es que la raíz
cuadrada de 27 a la podemos escribir
como la raíz cuadrada 9 por la raíz
cuadrada de 3
y en ambos casos nos hemos brindado un
paso aquí por ejemplo nos brincamos el
paso donde la raíz de 27 a la podemos
escribir como la raíz de 9
3a y entonces proceder a este paso pero
creo que hemos tenido suficiente
práctica para darnos cuenta que nueve
por tres a todo eso elevado a la
potencia un medio o que tomar la raíz
cuadrada principal de nueve por tres a
es lo mismo que tomar la raíz cuadrada
principal de nueve por la raíz cuadrada
principal de tres a eso fue lo que
hicimos aquí en ambos casos y espero que
eso ya no te cause confusión que tenemos
entonces la raíz de cuatro éstos
aquí la raíz de cuatro otra vez es igual
a 2 2 por 2 es igual a 4 que multiplica
la raíz de 3 a y eso le vamos a sumar la
raíz de 9 que es 3 por la raíz de 3 a
más 3 por la raíz de 3 y aquí otra vez 4
de algo más 3 de algo esto nos va a dar
igual esto va a ser igual a 7 de ese
algo en fin espero que esto te sea
sumamente útil